all right guys we got one more story for
you and this is a good coveted story
there is a chance people are fighting
back and although i think that if you
live in a blue state you really should
flee although only if you're coming here
to vote the right way um i do think that
there are signs that not everything is
absolutely
apocalyptic uh the new york mask mandate
is going to be reversed we've got a
quote here from the national review a
new york state supreme court judge on
monday ruled that governor kathy
hoechel's mass mandate for schools and
other public locations is
unconstitutional
judge thomas rademaker found that the
governor and the state health
commissioner did not have the authority
to enact a mask mandate without the
state legislature given that the
governor no longer has emergency powers
the mask mandate has been in place since
mid-december when the state saw a surge
in the highly trans transmissible
omicron variant there can be no question
that every
person in this state wishes wants and
prays that this era of covidan soon and
that they will surely do their part to
see that it is accomplished rademaker
wrote in his decision however enacting
any laws to this end is entrusted solely
to the state legislature while the
intentions of commissioner bassett and
governor hochul appear to be well aimed
squarely at doing what they believe is
right to protect the citizens of new
york state they must take their case to
the state legislature that's a pretty
clear explanation what's going on here
now i will add that at the end there
you're basically not impugning their
motives i've actually had it with these
people's motives i would say that hochel
who remember nobody voted for her she
was installed after they took out cuomo
nobody voted for her she has been the
worst sort of authoritarian so i don't
know what her motives are i do think
these people honestly get off on ruining
lives i think they get off on the power
of knowing that they can keep people in
masks that they can shut down businesses
i really do but let's put the motives
aside the the basis of the decision
there is that the governor is not the
king just because the governor wants to
do something you can't do it this is
what separation of powers is all about
the governor is supposed to be the chief
executive of the state the way the
president is the chief executive of the
country the president is not supposed to
make laws we have the legislature to
make laws right this is basic civics 101
i know you guys know all of this stuff
so the point is whether her intentions
are good or not she cannot just decide
you must wear masks to be in school you
must wear masks to be an employee of the
government etc etc so that shows you
that that beautiful system that we
created that no part of government was
going to get too much power that if you
if you chose to try to do something as
an executive that the legislature could
fight you on it and the judiciary would
decide what is legal it actually is
working even in as dysfunctional a place
as new york so there is hope and i will
keep finding the stories that give you
hope because i know not everyone can
live in florida i know it i know it
there is a lot of construction going on
here and a lot of people are coming here
and i should be sitting on the board of
florida tourism i'll talk to them about
that but the hope is that some of the
same people that remain in some of these
places can make sure they don't fully go
off the deep end
they they ain't going to be fixed at
least any time soon because so much of
this has become cult-like and psychotic
i would refer to you to uh segment one
about the view if you want more on that
however thankfully uh we've got some
good judges like rademaker up there in
new york and maybe some things will turn
around
foreign